sometimes you get like there's like a
little bit of like trauma bonding that
happens sometimes it goes the opposite
direction sometimes I make lifelong
friends doing this show you know what I
mean like it really is a range of
emotions [__] you Sean
you warm me up I say you're a nice guy I
literally felt we were about to be
friends and now I'm back to the gutter
of my hatred for Sean Evans what the
[__] have you done to me
[__] he said come and tie some [__]
Wings yeah my [__] really what the
[__] you know what you did
oh my God so the foodie Revolution
that's really infiltrated the sports
Stadium what does it really feel like
when one of those catfish feels a lot
better than these [__] Wings y'all
want to tell you that are you seriously
trying to do this interview still
where does a guy like you feel more at
home dude this is like with my wife
after a while you just tap out you're
like fine buy it I don't give a [__]
it's not okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay
that's awesome
dude why did I sign up for this man it
is always amazing to me why am I doing
this why am I here you were having a
good morning you know my life or my
world what am I you didn't need to [__]
it up like [__] am I doing here what's
your name Sean who are you why are we
here it's time to reach for that jug you
lied to me oh
guess what got me God
all right Shaq a [__] liar I have to
keep eating well you know what I can't I
can't what's wrong with you you don't
have to do anything I want to fight you
I understand I understand we're in this
together we're in this together but I
understand the impulse nobody's ever
whooped your ass after all these chicken
wings
stop the camera Mama go over there and
whoop your ass then we had Idris Alba on
he stopped the show and goes let me ask
you a question buddy sure
whose idea was this show so see that guy
right there yeah his name's Chris what's
your name Chris right
can you fight Chris
you might have to but you have to talk
about this
this is not normal you're normal that
shit's not normal that shit's inedible I
swear to God holy [__] it's still
burning
[Music]